what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and after months of shaking our fists
at marvel studios demanding a trailer
for the new eternals movie
it is finally here praise the celestials
hallelujah and good god is it looking
like a beautiful
blast from the past as this film is
confirmed to take place over the course
of thousands of years within the past of
the mcu as far back as the very origins
of mankind by the divine
sciences of the celestials and if
comments from fano's comic creator jim
starlin
are to be believed there was a good
chance that we might run into a certain
mad teenager from titan in chloe zhao's
new
eternals film as well that's right if
you think that we have seen the last of
thanos think again nerds
but before i get into those theories i
want to let you guys know that this
video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build your beautiful online presence
and run your business okay how like how
the hell
is a young thanos going to cameo in the
new eternals movie anyway well
i'm glad you asked because your boy mt
has got some theories
and i believe the most likely way that
we are going to see thatos in eternals
is via thanos's father
alars also known as the eternal mentor
now what makes mentor significant is
that he is the leader of the eternals on
saturn's moon of titan but
fun facts mentor is actually from a
little planet called
earth have you guys heard of it it's
that blue rock floating in space where
people take pictures of their feet for
money but that is not the only thing
that makes mentor an important figure in
marvel history because mentor is
actually the first
pure member of the eternal's race to be
referenced within the marvel cinematic
universe like remember
when thanos went to the planet vormir
with his very eatable daughter gamora
and they ran into the ghost of nazi past
well in that moment red skull calls
thanos
which directly points to the existence
of this eternal inside of the mcu now
the reason why i say mentor is the first
eternal reference and not thanos is
because
while thanos isn't eternal he's not 100
pure eternal or else he wouldn't look
like a giant purple ruffles chip
thanos was born with something called
deviant syndrome within his blood which
caused his appearance to look more
aligned with that of the deviant race
who are
the enemies of the eternals and the
genetic mistakes of the celestial
experimentation now if chloe zhao in
marvel studios are indeed telling the
story of earth's eternals that spans
thousands of years
it would be kind of difficult to do that
without at least touching on mentors
departure from earth thousands of years
in the past to form a new colony of
earth's eternals on
saturn's moon of titan now i believe
that when this exact story is told
through flashbacks that we could
actually get to see a montage that
features the birth and growth of the mad
titan himself
as he pops purple pimples and most
likely attempts to follow in his
father's footsteps as a scientist on the
moon of titan a scientist that would of
course eventually recommend planetary
genocide as a solution to titan's
dwindling resource problem a perspective
that i'm assuming that is due to the
very deviant mutation
within thanos's genes because if you
look at the eternals trailer it seems
that the eternals
have been charged by the celestials to
take care of humanity and if you're
thinking oh that's so nice the
celestials are so
sweet it's such such nice space robot
looking people
get that thought out of your mind okay
just remove it completely
because the celestials were only looking
after humanity because the human race
were their precious science experiments
because of all that neat cosmic stuff
that they did within humanity's dna
need cosmic stuff like the sg
anyways what i'm saying here is that it
is within the eternal's very nature to
advocate
for the preservation of life because
this is the very reason why they exist
in the first place
but because thanos's genes were mutated
by the deviant syndrome this innate
eternal draw
towards the preservation of life was
warped with a deviant type ruthless
mentality within thanos already heavily
logical science-based mind that he got
from his papa mentor now this would be a
great way to illustrate how mentally
[ __ ] up the deviant gene
can make you because while they weren't
featured within the eternals teaser
trailer
marvel studios official synopsis for the
movie confirms the deviance of the
planet earth to be a main antagonistic
force
for the eternals as they are in the
comics but before i continue like i said
before this video is sponsored by the
beautiful people at squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business want to start a
website for your business maybe your
cupcakes or graphic tees or coffee mugs
with very good superhero puns
are ready to hit the market and start
selling present your cool stuff
using squarespace's professional
portfolio design display projects in
customizable galleries
and you can auto post your content to
twitter facebook or tumblr and they have
built-in mobile websites and a really
slick mailing list
to stay in touch with your customers
squarespace will even sell you a url
which is great head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
that's squarespace.com through rockstars
for 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain but anyways that is just one way
thanos could appear in the new
eternals movie another way we could
potentially see a young thanos in
eternals is through direct contact with
the celestials themselves because think
about it the only person that i can
think of
in the mcu who had universally
devastating plans outside of thanos
and maybe malekith is the celestial ego
the living planet now if you think back
to the events of guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 you'll remember that the celestial
ego
had the power to influence peter's mind
and show him the cosmic perspective
and apparently that [ __ ] is so diesel
that peter quill was fully ready
to abandon his new family and the entire
universe
just because his sky daddy tapped him on
the forehead this is because star-lord
straight up saw the universe
the way that cosmic beings see the
universe and when you have the eyes of a
god you start to give as much of a [ __ ]
about the quality of life of mortal
beings
just as much as you would insects
outside of your house
now what if this very thing was done to
young thanos as well
like what if the reason why thanos is
called the mad titan
was because he had his mind touched and
driven mad
by the celestials and i can think of two
pretty good reasons why the celestials
could have done this to thanos with the
most obvious one being
you can't really conduct experiments on
life if all the life you experiment on
lives themselves to death because most
life in the mcu of course exists on
planets and those planets
have limited resources and sensitive
ecosystems and all of that
and the celestials are fully aware of
this yes the reproduction of life on
those planets is the very goal of the
celestials so that they can monitor
the evolutionary progress of various
races over time
but you can't check up on your lab rats
if all the lab rats
eat all of the cheese and set the maize
on fire while you're gone
so what do the celestials do they use an
eternal of course
because again as we can see from the
eternals trailer that's who the
celestials use
to conduct their lab rat maintenance and
what better eternal to use than the
genetically mutated
beast of a purple that is thanos of
titan like that dude is like super
strong and his deviant syndrome gives
him like super tough skin
the celestials could have been the very
force that initially gave thanos this
cosmic perspective
and the drive to start mowing the cosmic
lawn by killing off half of everything
that exists
this way not only do the people of these
planets get awarded more time to evolve
past their original expiration dates
but the celestials also buy themselves
more time to check up on the genetic and
evolutionary progress of their
experiments
throughout the universe because i don't
know if you guys heard this but the
universe
is pretty big almost as big as your mom
got him anyways the second reason i have
for the celestials introducing
themselves into
the life of a young thanos and driving
him crazy is something i like to call
the galactus imperative now in the
marvel comics the being known as
galactus doesn't eat entire planets in
one sitting
just because they taste like chicken
galactus was the universal custodian
and a vital part of the universe as a
whole it's a little complicated but the
long story short is if galactus stops
eating the universe will become crazy
unbalanced and the continued existence
of everything that is good will be
cancelled much like firefly
uh parks and rec or in my six-year
relationship
hello darkness my friend
and since galactus is being born at the
beginning of time but
has yet to be seen by anyone within the
marvel cinematic universe that we know
about
if this theory is correct i'm gonna go
ahead and assume that something happened
to galactus
at some point in the past and i'm also
willing to bet that the also
mia fantastic four had something to do
with it but that's not what this video
is about but regardless of how
galactus was removed from the equation
there's still a possibility
that the universe chose thanos as
galactus cosmic
understudy because what was one of the
last things thanos said before
thor went for the head roll the clip
john but the work is done
it always will be i am
inevitable like thanos seemed pretty
convinced that the fruits of his labor
were inevitable that something on such a
terribly devastating
universal scale has happened before and
will happen again even if he
is not the one to do it again because
the eternals are the celestial
babysitters of life i think that the
celestials could have given thanos the
universal
responsibility of cosmic balance that
galactus originally
had and if this theory is right and we
now live in a universe where thanos and
the celestial tools known as the
infinity stones are both
gone well the work now remains
unfinished which means that a new
universal threat
could be on the horizon the annihilation
wave perhaps
i don't know but i do know that papa
foggy has got to make the annihilation
wave happen at some point because
it's so good it's so good it's such a
good story guys you have to read it but
anyways those are just some ways that we
could see a young thanos appear in the
new eternals movie but
i have said nerd words long enough what
do you guys think my beautiful
nerd babies how do you guys think a
young thanos will appear in the new
eternals film let us know in the comment
section below and of course thank you
guys so much for watching this video and
if you want to watch me tweet the most
random things on the internet like a
madman
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter or on instagram but
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars on youtube and wherever else
we are on social media and make sure
make sure to hit the notification bell
so you get notifications whenever we
upload dope [ __ ] which is fairly
constant so you don't want to miss any
of it but anyways stay safe i love you
all deeply and i will see you guys
very soon catch you guys later
[Music]
you